It's delicate. It's beautiful. Sandy pulls out a handwritten page that's maybe three inches by five, tiny, black, perfect letters with brilliant orange and blue highlights on thin parchment.
它很精致。它很美。桑迪拿出一页手写纸，大约三乘五英寸，字迹细小、黑色、完美，在薄薄的羊皮纸上有明亮的橙色和蓝色装饰。
Look at how thin this is.
看看这个有多薄。
This is a page from another book--
这是另一本书的一页——
This is a page from a 13th century Parisian Bible. And there are hundreds, thousands of these. It was the required book for the University of Paris. There were thousands and thousands of students and professors at the University of Paris over several centuries.
这是13世纪巴黎圣经的一页。这样的书有成百上千本。这是巴黎大学的必修书。几个世纪以来，巴黎大学有成千上万的学生和教授。
And what's really amazing about it is that the writing is in two columns, and it looks too small to actually have been written by a human hand.
真正令人惊奇的是，书写分两栏，看起来太小了，不像是人手写出来的。
They invented eyeglasses in the 13th century.
他们在13世纪发明了眼镜。
Sandy is Sandy Hindman, director of an art gallery across from the Louvre that sells Medieval and Renaissance manuscripts, head of the art history department at Northwestern University. The reason she knows so much about manuscripts, she tells me, is that she doesn't know anything about anything else.
桑迪是桑迪·辛德曼（Sandy Hindman），她是卢浮宫对面一家出售中世纪和文艺复兴时期手稿的画廊的馆长，也是西北大学艺术史系主任。她告诉我，她之所以对手稿如此了解，是因为她对其他任何事情一窍不通。
So they're written all-- like, all, 99.9% of the manuscripts of the Middle Ages are written on parchment. And parchment is animal skin.
它们几乎全都是写在——你看，中世纪99.9%的手稿都是写在羊皮纸上的。而羊皮纸是动物皮。
Animal skin. Cows, goats, cats. And in the case of the delicate perfect page that she showed me, probably--
动物皮。牛、羊、猫。至于她给我看的这页精致完美的手稿，大概是——
This would be, like, a rat. If you take a whole rat, like this big, sort of the size of what--
这可能是一只老鼠。如果你拿一只像这么大的整只老鼠，大约是什么——
You're holding your hands about a foot apart.
你双手张开大约一英尺宽。
--a foot apart, and you skin it, that makes a bifolium, which is two of these pages. So that's what you would get. And then you'd have to get 600 of those animals to get a book.
——一英尺宽，把它剥皮，就能做成一个双叶，也就是两页。这就是你能得到的。然后你需要600只这样的动物才能做成一本书。
So we're thinking 600 rats, 600 cats, maybe.
所以我们想到的是600只老鼠，也许是600只猫。
Or squirrels or cats. The idea of cats has come up recently because they found all these cat bones, like a mound of cat bones, like a huge mound, like a burial site of cat bones right near the Seine where all the book-- where all the little book shops are now on the Seine, that's exactly where they were in the 15th century.
或者是松鼠或猫。关于猫的想法最近才出现，因为他们发现了所有这些猫骨头，像一座猫骨头堆，像一座巨大的堆，就像在塞纳河附近的一个猫骨头墓地，现在塞纳河边所有的小书店所在的地方，正是15世纪它们所在的地方。
Looking at these manuscripts with Sandy, I was really struck by just how complete our dominion is over the animal world, you know? That we could slaughter 300 cats or squirrels or rats or anything just to make this one little, little book.
和桑迪一起看这些手稿时，我真的被我们对动物世界拥有的完全统治权所震撼，你知道吗？我们竟然为了制作这唯一一本小书，就要屠杀300只猫、松鼠、老鼠或其他任何动物。
Now an eighth century book, like The Book of Kells, they say represented a herd of cattle. A Gutenberg Bible, like the first book ever printed is called the Gutenberg Bible, because he invented printing in 1452. So a Gutenberg Bible, each of those was a herd of cattle.
现在，8世纪的一本书，比如《凯尔经》，据说代表了一群牛。古腾堡圣经，就像有史以来印的第一本书被称为古腾堡圣经，因为他在1452年发明了印刷术。所以每一本古腾堡圣经，都是一群牛。
I think, what would Norman Mailer do, you know? Or David Foster Wallace, what would they do if a couple paragraphs, four paragraphs maybe, you can fit on these tiny pages, if that required the death of, you know, a cow or a cat for every single copy of one of their books? You know, it's no wonder that most of the books back then were religious. What human writing could seem worth it?
我在想，诺曼·梅勒会怎么做？或者大卫·福斯特·华莱士，如果他们能写在这几张小纸上的那四段话，每一本都需要牺牲一只牛或一只猫，他们会怎么做？难怪当时大多数书都是宗教书籍。什么样的人类写作看起来值得付出这样的代价呢？
What do we know, if anything, about attitudes in the Middle Ages towards killing off that many animals?
关于中世纪对杀掉这么多动物的态度，我们了解些什么吗？
I mean, I don't know anything really. I mean, my guess would be that since there are tons of colophons, that is, little inscriptions in the back, saying "Oh, I'm so pleased to have done this for you, God. This was wonderful. It was worth all the time." So probably they thought that it was great for the animal too. The animal was serving God just like they were by being in a book.
我的意思是，我真的什么都不知道。我想说，因为有大量的版权页，也就是后面的一些小铭文，写着“哦，我很高兴为你做这件事，上帝。这太美妙了。这一切时间都花得值。”所以他们可能也认为这对动物来说也是件好事。动物通过出现在书里，也像他们一样在侍奉上帝。
Faced with the fact of our sheer dominion over animals, there are only a few attitudes possible, really. Guilt, indifference, or piety. Which brings us to today's program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, animals, people, death, and God.
面对我们对动物拥有绝对统治权的事实，真的只有几种态度是可能的。内疚、冷漠或虔诚。这就引出了今天的节目。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题：动物、人类、死亡和上帝。
Act One of our program today, I'm Ferdinand, I'm Glad to Be Your Steak Tonight.
我们今天节目的第一幕，我是费迪南德，今晚很高兴成为你的牛排。
Act Two, the 400 Pound CEO, which is this amazing and funny and-- this is a story I just love by George Saunders.
第二幕，400磅重的首席执行官，这是一个乔治·桑德斯写的精彩而有趣的故事——我非常喜欢这个故事。
Act Three, Dead Animal Man.
第三幕，死动物人。
Act Four, Redemption. Stay with us.
第四幕，救赎。请继续收听。
Act One. What do we choose to believe about the sacrifices that animals make for us? Well, Jay Allison came up with this answer to that question.
第一幕。关于动物为我们做出的牺牲，我们选择相信什么？好吧，杰伊·艾利森对这个问题给出了这个答案。
When they came off of the ark, before they would disperse, remember, he said, God said to him, "Every beast of the field and fowl of the air shall become food unto you from this day on."
当他们从方舟出来时，在他们分散之前，记得吗，他说，上帝对他说：“凡地上的走兽和空中的飞鸟，从今天起都要成为你们的食物。”
A friend of mine, a classical pianist I know, had a dream that he was sleeping in his own room when something woke him up. Gathering at the foot of his bed was every animal he had ever even. They were just looking at him, breathing quietly. They pushed in closer and closer around his bed as more kept coming. Then when the room was full, the ones that came first started to file out through the bathroom door. And for the rest of the dream, each animal in turn simply paused by my friend's bed, looked at him, and passed on by to make room for the next one.
我有个朋友，一位古典钢琴家，他做过一个梦，梦见自己在房间里睡觉，被什么东西吵醒了。床脚聚集着他曾经吃过的每一种动物。它们只是看着他，安静地呼吸。随着越来越多的动物进来，它们在他床周围挤得越来越紧。然后当房间满了，最先来的那些开始从浴室门排队离开。在梦的其余时间里，每一只动物依次在他床边停下，看看他，然后走过去，为下一只让路。
I went to the slaughterhouses and I went out to the cattle ranches and places like that. And I talked to the animals, because I wanted to know if this was a really traumatic thing. It's like, I experience what the animal experiences. It's a vicarious experience. I feel their emotions. I think their thoughts. I literally become that animal. They show me what they look at, and what they see in life. And then I see it as they perceive it.
我去了屠宰场，去了养牛场之类的地方。我与动物交谈，因为我想知道这是否真的是一件创伤性的事情。这就像，我体验动物所经历的。这是一种替代体验。我感受它们的情绪。我思考它们的想法。我从字面上变成了那只动物。它们向我展示它们看的东西，以及它们在生活中看到的东西。然后我以它们感知的方式来看待它。
That door slides up. They come in here, and we kill them here. We lift this gate here, then the animal rolls out down here, and we put a chain around her leg. We use this chain the, put it right around her leg, a hind leg and pick them up.
那扇门滑上去。它们进到这里，我们就在这儿杀了它们。我们升起这道门，然后动物滚到下面这里，我们把链子绕在它的腿上。我们用这条链子，把它套在它的腿上，后腿，然后把它们吊起来。
So when I was there and I asked them how they felt, and they said they didn't mind giving their life for a purpose. And I watched the ones that were lifted upside down, where they tie them up by the back legs and then they slit the throat and the animal dies.
所以我当时在那里，我问它们感觉如何，它们说它们不介意为了一个目的而献出生命。我看着那些被倒挂起来的，它们被后腿绑住，然后割断喉咙，动物就死了。
We roll them over here and cut their throat, let the blood out of them.
我们把它们滚到这里，割开它们的喉咙，让血流出来。
They bleed to death. Well, I stood there and watched it, because I had to know if this was cruel. And those animals felt a lot of pain, but it was only like 30 seconds. And then, because they were upside down, all the organs pushed towards it. They cut off the blood supply. And the animals, when they actually had their throats cut, they were numb.
它们流血致死。好吧，我就站在那儿看着，因为我必须知道这是否残忍。那些动物感到了很大的痛苦，但只持续了30秒左右。然后，因为它们是倒挂着的，所有的器官都向头部挤压。它们切断了供血。当它们的喉咙被割开时，动物实际上是麻木的。
Roll them on across, lay them down in the cradles. Take their legs off, pick them up, and eviscerate them, split them down in the back then. Gives us two halves.
把它们滚到那边，放在架子上。把腿切掉，把它们吊起来，取出内脏，然后从背部剖开。给我们两半。
People say, "Oh, I couldn't see an animal die." Well, most of those animals wouldn't even live if it hadn't been for the fact that they were going to be raised for food. They wouldn't have even been born.
人们说：“哦，我不能看动物死亡。”好吧，如果不是为了养来做食物，大多数动物甚至根本活不下去。它们甚至根本就不会出生。
And they're rolled out into the cutting room and cut up into steaks, roasts, ground beef, then wrapped. Each package is labeled, and then we put it in the freezer.
然后它们被滚进切割室，切成牛排、烤肉、牛肉末，然后包装。每个包装都贴上标签，然后我们把它放进冷冻室。
You know, the animals tell me, most of the ones that are raised for food are raised very humanely. They're given the best of food, they're given the best of care. But they told me, no, that they felt that this was a purpose in life they were fulfilling. And they understood it, and they accepted the role because they were not afraid to die.
你知道，动物告诉我，大多数被养来做食物的动物都受到了非常人道的对待。它们得到了最好的食物，得到了最好的照顾。但它们告诉我，不，它们觉得这是它们正在实现的生活目标。它们理解这一点，并接受了这个角色，因为它们不怕死。
I don't believe that they know what's going on, really.
我不相信它们真的知道发生了什么。
Jay Allison, who did that story is the producer of Life Stories with his wife Christina Egloff.
做那个报道的杰伊·艾利森是《生活故事》的制作人，和他妻子克里斯蒂娜·埃格洛夫一起。
Act Two, The 400 Pound CEO. Well, animals and the death of animals are not the main point of this next story, but they do help define the moral universe of the story. This is a story by George Saunders. A quick warning. There is nothing explicit, there's no nasty language, nothing like that in this story. But, but, but, some references and ideas might not be suitable for some children.
第二幕，400磅重的首席执行官。好吧，动物和动物的死亡并不是下一个故事的主要重点，但它们确实有助于定义故事的道德世界。这是一个乔治·桑德斯的故事。简短的警告。这个故事里没有什么露骨的东西，没有肮脏的语言，没有类似的东西。但是，但是，但是，一些参考资料和想法可能不适合一些孩子。
At noon, another load of raccoons comes in, and Claude takes them out back of the office and executes them with a tire iron. Then he checks for vitals wearing protective gloves. Then he drags the cage across 209 and initiates burial by dumping the raccoons into the pit that's our little corporate secret. After burial comes prayer, a personal touch that never fails to irritate Tim, our ruthless CEO.
中午，又一批浣熊送来了，克劳德把它们带到办公室后面，用轮胎撬棍处决了它们。然后他戴着防护手套检查生命体征。然后他把笼子拖过209号公路，通过把浣熊倒进那个属于我们公司小秘密的坑里来开始埋葬。埋葬后是祈祷，这是一个从来不会失败而惹恼我们冷酷的首席执行官蒂姆的个人风格。
Before founding Humane Raccoon Alternatives, Tim purposely backed his car over a frat boy and got 10 to 12 for manslaughter. In jail, he earned his MBA by designing and marketing a line of light-up Halloween lapel broaches. Now he gives us the broaches as performance incentives and sporadically trashes a bookshelf or two to remind us of his awesome temper and of how ill-advised we'd be to cross him in any way whatsoever.
在创立“人道浣熊替代方案”之前，蒂姆故意倒车压死了一个大学兄弟会成员，并因过失杀人罪被判了10到12年。在监狱里，他通过设计和营销一系列发光的万圣节翻领胸针获得了工商管理硕士学位。现在他把这些胸针作为绩效奖励发给我们，并偶尔砸坏一两个书架，以提醒我们他那可怕的脾气，以及以任何方式阻碍他是多么不明智。
Post-burial, I write up the invoices and a paragraph or two on how overjoyed the raccoons were when we set them free. Sometimes I'll throw in something about spontaneous mating beneath the box elders. No one writes a better misleading letter than me. In the area of phone inquiries, I'm also unsurpassed. When a client calls to ask how their release went, everyone in the office falls all over themselves transferring the call to me. I'm reassuring and joyful. I laugh until tears run down my face at the stories I make up regarding the wacky things their raccoon did upon gaining its freedom.
埋葬后，我写发票，并写上一两段关于当我们放走浣熊时它们是多么高兴的内容。有时我会加一些关于在盒状枫树下自发交配的内容。没有人写出的误导信比我写得更好。在电话咨询方面，我也是无与伦比的。当客户打电话询问他们的释放情况如何时，办公室里的每个人都会争先恐后地把电话转给我。我让人感到安心且快乐。我笑得眼泪直流，讲述着我编造的关于他们浣熊在获得自由后所做的滑稽事情的故事。
Then, as per Tim, I ask if they'd mind sending back our promotional materials. The brochures don't come cheap. They show glossies of raccoons in the wild contrasted with glossies of poisoned raccoons in their death throes. You lay that on a housewife with perennially knocked-over trash cans and she breathes a sigh of relief. Then she hires you and you get a 10% commission.
然后，按照蒂姆的要求，我问他们是否介意寄回我们的宣传资料。这些小册子可不便宜。它们展示了野外浣熊的光面照片，与垂死中毒浣熊的光面照片形成了对比。你把这个展示给那些垃圾桶经常被翻倒的主妇看，她会如释重负。然后她雇佣了你，你就能得到10%的佣金。
These days, commissions are my main joy. I'm too large to attract female company. I weigh 400. I don't like it, but it's beyond my control. I've tried running and rowing the stationary canoe and Hatha yoga and belly staples and even a muzzle back in the dark days when I had it bad for Frieda, our document placement and retrieval specialist. When I was merely portly, it was easy to see myself as a kind of exuberant sportsman who overate out of lust for life. Now, no one could possibly mistake me for a sportsman.
这些天，佣金是我主要的快乐。我太胖了，吸引不到女性朋友。我体重400磅。我不喜欢这样，但这是我无法控制的。我试过跑步、划固定划船机、哈达瑜伽、腹部钉合，甚至在我疯狂迷恋弗里达（我们的文件放置和检索专家）的那段黑暗日子里戴过口套。当我仅仅是胖乎乎的时候，很容易把自己看作是一个因为热爱生活而吃得过多的充满活力的运动员。现在，没有人会把我错认成运动员。
When I've finished invoicing, I enjoy a pecan cluster. Two, actually. Claude comes in all dirty from the burial and sees me snacking and feels compelled to point out that even my sub-rolls have sub-rolls. He's right, but still it isn't nice to say. Tim asks did Claude make that observation after having wild sex with me all night? That's a comment I'm not fond of, but Tim's the boss. His T-shirt says, "I hold your purse strings in my hot, little hand."
当我开完发票，我享受一颗胡桃巧克力。实际上是两颗。克劳德从埋葬地回来，浑身脏兮兮的，看到我在吃零食，就不得不指出即使我的副卷里还有副卷。他是对的，但这话说出来并不好听。蒂姆问克劳德是不是在跟我疯狂做爱一整晚后观察到的？那是我不喜欢听到的评论，但蒂姆是老板。他的T恤上写着：“我把你钱包的系带握在我火热的小手里。”
"Haha, Tim," says Claude. "I'm no homo. But if I was one, I'd die before doing it with Mr. Lard."
“哈哈，蒂姆，”克劳德说。“我不是同性恋。但如果我是，我宁愿死也不会和猪油先生做那种事。”
"Haha," says Tim. "Good one. Isn't that a good one, Jeffrey?"
“哈哈，”蒂姆说。“好样的。这不是很好吗，杰弗里？”
"That's a good one," I say glumly.
“这很好，”我郁闷地说。
What a bitter little office. My colleagues leave hippo refrigerator magnets on my seat. They imply that I'm a despondent virgin, which I'm not. They might change their tune if they ever spoke with Ellen Burtomly regarding the beautiful night we spent at her brother Bob's cottage. I was by no means slim then but could at least buy pants off the rack and walk from the den to the kitchen without panting. I remember her nude at the window and the lovely seed helicopters blowing in as she turned and showed me her ample front on purpose.
多么刻薄的小办公室。我的同事在我的座位上留下河马冰箱贴。他们暗示我是一个沮丧的处男，但我不是。如果他们曾经和艾伦·伯特姆利谈过我们在她哥哥鲍勃的小屋里度过的那个美妙夜晚，他们可能会改变调子。那时我绝不苗条，但至少能买到现成的裤子，走从书房到厨房的路而不喘气。我记得她裸体站在窗前，可爱的种子直升机（枫树种子）吹进来，她转过身，故意向我展示她丰满的前胸。
That was my most romantic moment. Now for that kind of thing, it's the degradation of Larney's Consenting Adult Viewing Center. Before it started getting to me, I'd bring boot-loads of quarters and a special bottom cushion and watch hours and hours of Scandinavian women romping. It was shameful. Finally, last Christmas, I said enough is enough. I'd rather be sexless than evil. And since then, I have been. Sexless and good, but very, very tense.
那是我最浪漫的时刻。现在为了那种事，只能去拉尼的成人视听中心那种堕落的地方。在它开始影响我之前，我会带一车一车的硬币和一个特殊的底部垫子，看上好几个小时斯堪的纳维亚女人嬉戏。那太可耻了。最后，去年圣诞节，我说受够了。我宁愿无性也不愿邪恶。从那时起，我一直是这样。无性且善良，但非常、非常紧张。
Since then, I've tried to live above the fray. I've tried to minimize my physical aspects and be a selfless force for good. When mocked, which is nearly every day, I recall Christ covered with spittle. When filled with lust, I remember Gandhi purposely sleeping next to a sexy teen to test himself. After work, I go home, watch a little TV, maybe say a rosary or two. 30 more years of this and I'm out of it without hurting anybody or embarrassing myself.
从那时起，我试图生活在纷争之上。我试图最小化我的身体方面，成为一股无私的善的力量。当被嘲笑时，几乎每天都是，我就想起布满唾沫的基督。当充满欲望时，我记住甘地故意睡在一个性感少女旁边来考验自己。下班后，我回家，看会儿电视，也许念一两串玫瑰经。再这样过30年，我就解脱了，不伤害任何人，也不让自己尴尬。
Sadly, I find my feelings for Frieda returning. I must have a death wish. Clearly I repulse her. Sometimes I catch her looking at my gut overhangs with a screwed-up face. I see her licking her lips while typing and certain unholy thoughts go through my head. I hear her speaking tenderly on the phone to her little son Len and can't help picturing myself sitting on a specially reinforced porch swing while she fries up some chops and Len digs in the muck.
可悲的是，我发现我对弗里达的感觉又回来了。我一定有自杀倾向。显然，我令她作呕。有时我看到她看着我肚子上的赘肉，一脸扭曲。我看到她打字时舔着嘴唇，某些邪恶的想法就出现在我的脑海里。我听见她在电话里温柔地跟她的小儿子伦说话，不禁想象自己坐在一个特制的加固门廊秋千上，而她在炸排骨，伦在泥里挖东西。
Today as we prepare a mailer, she says she's starting to want to be home with Len all the time. But there's the glaring problem of funds. She makes squat. I've seen her stub. There's the further problem that she suspects Mrs. Rasputin, Len's babysitter, is a lush. "I don't know what to do," Frieda says. I come home after work and she's sitting there tipsy in her bra, fanning herself with a racing form. Before I know what I'm saying, I suggest that perhaps we should go out for dinner and offer each other some measure of comfort.
今天当我们准备邮件时，她说她开始想一直待在家里陪伦。但有一个明显的资金问题。她赚得极少。我看过她的工资单。还有一个更严重的问题是，她怀疑伦的保姆拉斯普京太太是个酒鬼。“我不知道该怎么办，”弗里达说。我下班回家，她坐在那里，穿着胸罩，醉醺醺的，用赛马报纸给自己扇风。我还没反应过来自己在说什么，就建议或许我们可以出去吃晚饭，互相给予一些安慰。
In response, she spits her Tab out across her cubicle. She says now she's heard it all. She goes to fetch Tim and Claude so they can join her in guffawing at my nerve. She faxes a comical note about my arrogance to her girlfriend at the DMV. All afternoon, she keeps looking at me with her head cocked. Needless to say, it's a long day.
作为回应，她把Tab汽水喷到了隔间外面。她说她现在什么都听到了。她去找蒂姆和克劳德，好让他们加入她，嘲笑我的胆量。她给车管所的女朋友发了一份关于我傲慢的滑稽传真。整个下午，她一直歪着头看着我。不用说，这是漫长的一天。
Then at 5:00, after everyone else is gone, she comes shyly by and says she'd love to go out with me. She says I've always been there for her. She says she likes a man with a little meat on his bones. She says pick her up at 8:00 and bring something for Len. I'm shocked. I'm overjoyed. My knees are nearly shaking my little desk apart.
然后在5点钟，在其他人都走后，她羞怯地走过来，说她很乐意和我出去。她说我一直都在支持她。她说她喜欢有点肉的男人。她说8点钟来接她，带点东西给伦。我震惊了。我欣喜若狂。我的膝盖几乎要把我的小书桌震散架了。
I buy Len a football helmet and a baseball glove and an aquarium and a set of encyclopedias. I basically clean out my pitiful savings. Who cares? It's worth it to get a chance to observe her beautiful face from across a table without Claude et al. hooting at me.
我给伦买了一个橄榄球头盔、一个棒球手套、一个水族箱和一套百科全书。我基本上掏空了我可怜的积蓄。谁在乎呢？能有机会在桌子对面观察她美丽的脸，而没有克劳德他们对我嘲讽，这就值了。
When I ring her bell, someone screams, "Come in." Inside, I find Len behind the home entertainment center and Mrs. Rasputin drunkenly poring over her grade school yearbook with a highlighter.
当我按响她的门铃时，有人尖叫道：“进来。”里面，我发现伦在家庭娱乐中心后面，而拉斯普京太太喝醉了，正用荧光笔研读她小学时的毕业纪念册。
She looks up and says, "Where's that kid?"
她抬头说：“那孩子呢？”
I feel like saying, "How should I know?" Instead I say, "He's behind the home entertainment center."
我真想说：“我怎么知道？”相反，我说：“他在家庭娱乐中心后面。”
"He loves it back there," she says. "He likes eating the lint balls. They won't hurt him. They're like roughage."
“他喜欢待在那里，”她说。“他喜欢吃棉絮球。它们不会伤害他。它们就像粗纤维。”
"Come out, Len," I say. "I have gifts." He comes out. One tiny eyebrow cocks up at my physical appearance. Then he crawls into my lap holding his Mega Death Dealer by the cowl. What a sweet boy. The Dealer's got a severed human head in its hand. When you pull the string, the Dealer cries, "You're dead and I've killed you, Prince of Slime," and sticks its Day-Glo tongue out. I give Len my anti-violence spiel. I tell him only love can dispel hate. I tell him we were meant to live in harmony and give one another emotional support. He looks at me blankly then flings his Death Dealer at the cat.
“出来吧，伦，”我说。“我有礼物。”他出来了。一个小眉毛因为我的外表而扬起。然后他抱着他的“超级死亡贩卖者”爬到我怀里。多可爱的男孩。贩卖者手里有一个被砍下的人类头骨。当你拉绳子时，贩卖者会喊：“你死定了，我已经杀了你，史莱姆王子，”并伸出荧光舌头。我给了伦一套反暴力演说。我告诉他只有爱才能消除仇恨。我告诉他我们注定要和谐相处，互相给予情感支持。他茫然地看着我，然后把他的死亡贩卖者扔向猫。
Frieda comes down looking sweet and casts a baleful eye on Mrs. Rasputin and away we go. I take her to Ace's Volcano Island. Ace's is an old service station now done up Hawaiian. They've got a tape loop of surf sounds and some Barbies in grass skirts climbing a paper mache mountain. I purposely starve myself.
弗里达走下来，看起来很甜美，向拉斯普京太太投去不满的一眼，我们就出发了。我带她去阿斯的火山岛。阿斯以前是个服务站，现在装潢成了夏威夷风格。他们循环播放海浪声，还有几个穿着草裙的芭比娃娃在爬纸糊的山。我故意让自己挨饿。
We talk about her life philosophy. We talk about her hair style and her treasured childhood memories and her paranormally gifted aunt. I fail to get a word in edgewise, and that's fine. I like listening. I like learning about her. I like putting myself in her shoes and seeing things her way.
我们谈论她的人生哲学。我们谈论她的发型、她珍贵的童年记忆和她那位有超自然天赋的阿姨。我没能插上一句话，但这很好。我喜欢倾听。我喜欢了解她。我喜欢设身处地，以她的方式看事情。
I walk her home. Kids in doorways whistle at my width. I handle it with grace by shaking my rear. Frieda laughs. A kiss seems viable. It all feels too good to be true. Then on her porch, she shakes my hand and says great, she can now pay her phone bill, courtesy of Tim. She shows me the written agreement. It says, "In consideration of your consenting to be seen in public with Jeffrey, I, Tim, will pay you, Frieda, the sum of $50."
我送她回家。门口的孩子们对我的身材吹口哨。我摇晃着屁股优雅地应对了。弗里达笑了。亲吻似乎很有可能。一切感觉太好而不像是真的。然后在她的门廊上，她握了握我的手，说太棒了，她现在可以支付她的电话费了，多亏了蒂姆。她给我看了书面协议。上面写着：“鉴于你同意在公共场合与杰弗里一起露面，我，蒂姆，将支付给你，弗里达，50美元。”
I take a weekend vacation and play Oilcan Man nonstop. I achieve level nine. At the end of night three, I step outside for some air. Up in the sky are wild clouds that make me think of Tahiti and courageous sailors on big sinking wooden ships. Meanwhile, here's me, a grown man with a joystick burn on his thumb.
我请了一个周末假，不停地玩《油罐人》。我达到了第九级。第三天晚上结束时，我走到外面透透气。天上的野云让我想起塔希提岛和在大沉木船上的勇敢水手。与此同时，看看我，一个大拇指上有操纵杆烧伤的大男人。
So I throw the game cartridge in the trash and go back to work. I take the ribbing, I take the abuse. Someone snipped my head out of the office folder and mounted it on a bride's body. Tim says, what the heck, the thought of the visual incongruity of our pairing was worth the $50.
所以我把游戏卡带扔进垃圾桶，回去工作。我接受嘲笑，我接受侮辱。有人剪掉了我在办公室文件夹里的头像，把它贴在了一个新娘的身体上。蒂姆说，管他呢，想到我们这种配对的视觉不和谐感值那50美元。
"Do you hate me?" Frieda asks.
“你恨我吗？”弗里达问。
"No," I say, "I truly enjoyed our evening together."
“不，”我说，“我真的很享受我们在一起的那个晚上。”
"God, I didn't," she says. "Everyone kept staring at us. It made me feel bad about myself that they thought I was actually with you. Do you know what I mean?" I can't think of anything to say so I nod. Then I retreat moist-eyed to my cubicle for some invoicing fun.
“天哪，我没有，”她说。“每个人都在盯着我们看。想到他们认为我真的和你在一起，让我对自己感觉很糟糕。你知道我的意思吗？”我想不出什么可说的，就点点头。然后我泪眼朦胧地退回到我的隔间去享受开票的乐趣。
I'm not a bad guy. If only I could stop hoping. If only I could say to my heart, "Give up. Be alone forever. There's always opera. There's angel food cake and neighborhood children caroling and the look of autumn leaves on a wet roof." But no. My heart's some kind of idiotic fishing bobber. My invoices go very well. The sun sinks, the moon rises, brown and pale as my stupid face.
我不是个坏人。如果我能停止希望就好了。如果我能对我的心说：“放弃吧。永远孤独。总还有歌剧。还有天使蛋糕和社区孩子们唱赞美诗，还有湿屋顶上的秋叶景色。”但没有。我的心就像某种愚蠢的钓鱼浮标。我的发票处理得很好。太阳沉下去，月亮升起来，棕色又苍白，像我那张愚蠢的脸。
I minimize my office time by volunteering for the Carlisle entrapment. The Carlisles are rich. A poor guy has a raccoon problem, he sprinkles poison in his trash and calls it a day. Not the Carlisles. They dominate bread routes throughout the city. Carlisle supposedly strong-armed his way to the top of the bread heap, but in person, he's nice enough.
我通过自愿参加卡莱尔捕获行动来尽量减少办公室时间。卡莱尔一家很有钱。穷人如果有浣熊问题，会在垃圾里撒点毒药然后就完事了。卡莱尔家可不是。他们统治着整个城市的面包路线。卡莱尔据说是一路强买强卖到了面包业的顶峰，但私下里，他还是挺友好的。
I let him observe me laying out the rotten fruit. I show him how the cage door coming down couldn't hurt a flea. Then he goes inside and I wait patiently in my car. Just after midnight, I trip the wire. I fetch the Carlisles and encourage them to squat down and relate to the captured raccoon. Then I recite our canned speech congratulating them for their advance thinking. I describe the wilderness where the release will take place, the streams and fertile valleys, the romp in the raccoon's stride when it catches its first whiff of pristine air.
我让他观察我摆放腐烂的水果。我向他展示了笼门关下来是怎么连只跳蚤都伤不了的。然后他进屋了，我在车里耐心等待。午夜刚过，我触发了电线。我叫来卡莱尔一家，鼓励他们蹲下来，与被捕获的浣熊交流。然后我背诵了我们的预设演讲，祝贺他们的超前思考。我描述了将要进行释放的荒野、溪流和肥沃的山谷，浣熊在闻到第一口原始空气时的脚步。
Mr. Carlisle says thanks for letting him sleep at night sans guilt. I tell him that's my job. Just then, the raccoon's huge mate bolts out of the woods and tears into my calf. I struggle to my car and kick the mate repeated against my wheel well until it dies with my leg in its mouth. The Carlisles stand aghast in the carport. I stand aghast in the driveway, sick at heart. I've trapped my share of raccoons and helped Claude with more burials than I care to remember, but I've never actually killed anything before.
卡莱尔先生说谢谢我让他晚上不用愧疚。我告诉他那是我的工作。就在这时，浣熊的巨大配偶冲出树林，撕咬我的小腿。我挣扎着回到车里，不停地用那只浣熊踢我的轮拱，直到它嘴里咬着我的腿死掉。卡莱尔一家在车棚里惊呆了。我站在车道上惊呆了，心里很难受。我抓过不少浣熊，帮克劳德处理过我记不清的那么多次埋葬，但我以前从未真正杀过任何东西。
I throw both coons in the trunk and drive myself to the emergency room, where I'm given the first of a series of extremely painful shots. I doze off on a bench post-treatment and dream of a den of pathetic baby raccoons in V-neck sweaters yelping for food. When I wake up, I call in. Tim asks if I'm crazy kicking a raccoon to death in front of clients. Couldn't I have gently lifted it off, he asks, or offered it some rotting fruit? Am I proud of my ability to screw up one-car funerals?
我把两只浣熊扔进后备箱，开车去急诊室，在那里我接受了第一针非常痛苦的注射。治疗后我在长椅上打瞌睡，梦见一个穿着V领毛衣的可怜小浣熊窝在为食物尖叫。醒来后，我打电话请假。蒂姆问我是不是疯了，在客户面前把一只浣熊踢死。他问，我难道不能轻轻把它挪开，或者给它点腐烂的水果吗？我对把单车葬礼搞砸的能力感到自豪吗？
I tell Tim I'm truly sorry I didn't handle the situation more effectively. He says the raccoon must've had a said last couple of minutes once it realized it had given up its life for the privilege of gnawing on a shank of pure fat. That hurts. Why I continue to expect decent treatment from someone who's installed a torture chamber in the corporate basement is beyond me. Down there, he's got a Hide-A-Bed and a whip collection and an executioner's mask with a built-in Walkman. Sometimes when I'm invoicing late, he'll bring in one of his willing victims. Usually, they're both wasto.
我告诉蒂姆我真的很抱歉没有更有效地处理这种情况。他说那只浣熊在意识到它为了啃一口纯脂肪的腿骨而献出生命后，最后的几分钟一定过得很悲惨。这很伤人。为什么我还要继续期待一个在公司地下室安装了刑讯室的人给予体面的对待，我简直无法理解。在那下面，他有一张隐藏式床铺和一套鞭子收藏，还有一个内置随身听的行刑者面具。有时当我在深夜开票时，他会带一个愿意的受害者进来。通常，他们都喝醉了。
I get as much of me under my desk as I can. Talk about the fall of man. Talk about some father somewhere being crestfallen if he knew what his daughter was up to. Once I peeked out as they left and saw a blonde with a black eye going wherever Tim pointed and picking up his coat whenever he purposely dropped it. How do people get like this? I thought. Can they change back? Can they learn again to love and be gentle? How can they look at themselves in the mirror or hang Christmas ornaments without overflowing with self-loathing?
我尽量把自己藏在桌子底下。谈谈人类的堕落吧。谈谈某个父亲如果知道他女儿在干什么会多么失望。有一次我偷看了一眼他们离开时，看到一个黑眼圈的金发女郎随着蒂姆指的地方走，并在他故意扔掉外套时捡起来。人们怎么会变成这样？我想。他们能变回来吗？他们能再次学会去爱和温柔吗？他们怎么能照镜子或者挂圣诞饰品而不充满自我厌恶呢？
Then I thought, I may be obese, but at least I'm not cruel to the point of being satanic. The next day, Tim was inducted into Rotary and we all went to the luncheon. He spoke on turning one's life around. He spoke on the bitter lessons of incarceration. He sang the praises of America and joked with balding, sweetheart ophthalmologists and after lunch hung his Rotary plaque in the torture chamber stairwell and ordered me to Windex it daily or face extremely grim consequences.
然后我想，我可能肥胖，但至少我不残忍到邪恶的地步。第二天，蒂姆被引入扶轮社，我们都去了午餐会。他谈到了改变人生。他谈到了监禁的痛苦教训。他歌颂美国，和秃顶、甜心的眼科医生开玩笑，午饭后把他的扶轮社奖牌挂在刑讯室的楼梯间，并命令我每天用玻璃清洁剂擦拭，否则面临极其严重的后果。
Tuesday, a car pulls up as Claude and I approach the burial pit with the Carlisle raccoons. We drag the cage into a shrub and squat, panting. Claude whispers that I smell. He whispers that if he weighed 400, he'd take into account that people around him and go on a diet. A pale girl in a sari gets out of the car and walks to the lip of the pit. She paces off the circumference and scribbles in a notebook. She takes photos. She slides down on her rear and comes back up with some coon bones in a baggy. After she leaves, we rush back to the office.
周二，当克劳德和我带着卡莱尔家的浣熊走向埋葬坑时，一辆车停了下来。我们把笼子拖进灌木丛，蹲着喘气。克劳德悄悄说我身上有味。他悄悄说如果他有400磅，他会考虑到周围的人，去节食。一个穿纱丽的苍白女孩从车里出来，走到坑边。她量了周长，在笔记本上乱涂乱画。她拍照。她向后滑下去，带着一些浣熊骨头装在塑料袋里上来。她走后，我们冲回办公室。
Tim's livid and starts baby-oiling his trademark blackjack. He says no more coons in the pit until further notice. He says we're hereby in crisis mode and will keep the coons on blue ice in our cubicles and if need be, wear nose clips. He says the next time she shows up, he may have to teach her a lesson about jeopardizing our meal ticket. He says animal rights are all well and good, but there's a big difference between a cute bunny or cat and a disgusting raccoon that thrives on carrion and trash and creates significant sanitation problems with its inquisitiveness.
蒂姆勃然大怒，开始给他的招牌黑杰克棍抹婴儿油。他说除非另行通知，否则坑里不再放浣熊。他说我们现在进入危机模式，要把浣熊放在隔间的蓝色冰块上，如有必要，戴上鼻夹。他说下次她再出现，他可能得给她上一课，关于危及我们饭碗的事。他说动物权利确实很好，但可爱的兔子或猫和以食腐和垃圾为生，因好奇心造成严重卫生问题的恶心浣熊之间有很大区别。
"Oh, get off it," Claude says, affection for Tim shining from his dull eyes. "You'd eliminate your own mother if there was a buck in it for you."
“哦，别说了，”克劳德说，他迟钝的眼睛里闪烁着对蒂姆的喜爱。“如果里面有钱赚，你连自己的母亲都会消灭掉。”
"Undeniably," Tim says, "especially if she knocked over a client trash can or turned rabid. Then he hands me the corporate Visa and sends me to Hardware Niche for coolers.
“不可否认，”蒂姆说，“尤其是如果她翻倒了客户的垃圾桶或者得了狂犬病。”然后他把公司信用卡给我，让我去五金店买冷藏箱。
When I get back to the office, everyone's gone for the night. The Muzak's off for a change and loud wax and harsh words are floating up from the basement via the heat ducts. Before long, Tim tromps up the stairs swearing. I hide pronto. He shouts thanks for nothing and says he could have had more rough and tumble fun dangling a cat over a banister, that there's nothing duller than a clerk with the sexual imagination of a grape.
当我回到办公室时，大家都下班走了。背景音乐难得关了，从地下室通过暖气管道飘上来很大的响声和刺耳的话语。没过多久，蒂姆骂骂咧咧地走上楼梯。我立刻躲了起来。他大喊谢谢什么都没做，说他本可以把一只猫在栏杆上晃来晃去享受更多乐趣，没有什么比一个性想象力像葡萄一样的店员更无聊的了。
"Document placement and retrieval specialist," Frieda says in a hurt tone.
“文件放置和检索专家，”弗里达受伤地说。
"Whatever," Tim says and speeds off in his Porsche.
“管他呢，”蒂姆说，开着他的保时捷疾驰而去。
I emerge overwhelmed from my cubicle. Over her shoulder and through the plate glass is a shocked autumnal moon. Frieda's cheek is badly bruised. Otherwise, she's radiant with love. My mouth hangs open. "What can I say?" she says. "I can't get enough of the man."
我不知所措地从隔间里冒出来。在她的肩膀上方，穿过平板玻璃是一个震惊的秋月。弗里达的脸颊上有严重的瘀伤。除此之外，她洋溢着爱。我的嘴张大了。“我能说什么？”她说。“我对他爱不够。”
"Good night," I say and forget about my car and walked the nine miles home in a daze.
“晚安，”我说，忘了我的车，在恍惚中走了9英里回家。
All day Wednesday, I prepare to tell Tim off, but I'm too scared. Plus he could rightly say she's a consenting adult. Instead, I drop a few snots in his coffee cup and use my network access privileges to cancel his print jobs. He asks can I work late, and in spite of myself, I fawningly say sure. I hate him. I hate myself.
整个周三，我准备告诉蒂姆别这样，但我太害怕了。加上他可以说她是一个有行为能力的成年人。相反，我在他的咖啡杯里滴了几滴鼻涕，并利用我的网络访问权限取消了他的打印任务。他问我能不能加班，尽管我不情愿，还是谄媚地说了当然。我恨他。我恨我自己。
Everybody else goes home. Big clouds roll in. I invoice like mad. Birds light on the dumpster and feed on substances caked on the lid. What a degraded cosmos. What a case of something starting out nice and going bad.
其他人都回家了。大云滚滚而来。我疯狂地开着发票。鸟儿落在垃圾桶上，吃着盖子上的渣滓。多么堕落的宇宙。一个美好的事物开始并变坏的案例。
More of George Saunders' story, "The 400 Pound CEO" in a minute when our program continues.
乔治·桑德斯的故事《400磅重的首席执行官》更多部分，在我们节目继续时回来。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, documentary producers, and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, Animals Die, People Ponder Morality. We are in the middle or Act Two, George Saunders' story, "The 400 Pound CEO" continues. At this point in the story, it's late, our narrator has just discovered that Frieda loves his boss Tim. He hates Tim, but he works late for him that day anyway. Tim stays late too.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、纪录片制片人和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，《动物死亡，人类思考道德》。我们正处于第二幕中间，乔治·桑德斯的故事《400磅重的首席执行官》继续。此时在故事中，天色已晚，我们的叙述者刚刚发现弗里达爱他的老板蒂姆。他恨蒂姆，但他那天还是为他加班了。蒂姆也留得很晚。
Just after 7:00, I hear him shout, "You, darling, will rot in hell with the help of a swift push to the grave from me." At first, I think he's pillow talking with Frieda by phone. Then I look out the window and see the animal rights girl at the lip of our pit with a camcorder. Tim runs out the door with his blackjack unsheathed.
7点过后，我听见他大喊：“你，亲爱的，会下地狱的，我会帮你一把，把你推进坟墓。”起初，我以为他在电话里跟弗里达调情。然后我向窗外看，看到动物权利女孩在我们的坑边拿着摄像机。蒂姆拔出他的黑杰克棍跑出门外。
What to do? Clearly, he means her harm. I follow him, leaving behind my loafers to minimize noise. I keep to the shadows and scurry in my socks from tiny berm to tiny berm. I heave in an unattractive manner. My heart rate's in the ionosphere. To my credit, I'm able to keep up with him. Meanwhile, she's struggling up the slope with her hair in sweet disarray, backlit by a moon the color of honey, camcorder on her head like some kind of Kenyan water jug.
该怎么办？显然，他想伤害她。我跟着他，为了减少噪音，撇下了我的乐福鞋。我躲在阴影里，穿着袜子在小土堆间疾走。我不雅观地喘着气。我的心率在电离层里。值得称赞的是，我能跟上他。与此同时，她正挣扎着爬上斜坡，头发凌乱，被蜂蜜色的月光映衬着，摄像机戴在头上像个肯尼亚水罐。
"Harlot," Tim hisses, "attempted defiler of my dream," and whips his blackjack down. Am I quick? I am so quick. I lunge up and take it on the wrist. My arm bone goes to mush and my head starts to spin and I wrap Tim up in a hug the size of Tulsa.
“妓女，”蒂姆嘶嘶地说，“我梦想的企图污秽者，”并挥下他的黑杰克棍。我快吗？我太快了。我扑上去，用手腕接住了那一棍。我的胳膊骨头变软了，头开始旋转，我用塔尔萨那么大的拥抱把蒂姆包住了。
"Run," I gasp to the girl and see in the moonlight the affluent white souls of her fleeing boat-type shoes. I hug hard. I tell him drop the jack, and to my surprise, he does. Do I then release him? To my shame, no. So much sick rage is stored up in me. I never knew. And out it comes in one mondo squeeze and something breaks and he goes limp and I lay him gently down in the dirt.
“跑，”我对着女孩喘气，在月光下看到她那逃跑的平底鞋那富裕的白色鞋底。我紧紧拥抱。我告诉他放下棍子，令我惊讶的是，他照做了。我当时放开他了吗？令我羞愧的是，没有。我体内积攒了太多病态的愤怒。我从不知道。它一下子释放出来，我用力一挤，什么东西断了，他瘫软下来，我轻轻把他放下土里。
I CPR like anything. I beg him to rise up and thrash me. I do a crazy little dance of grief. But it's no good. I've killed Tim.
我尽我所能做心肺复苏。我求他起来打我。我跳了一段疯狂的悲伤小舞。但没用。我杀了蒂姆。
I sprint across 209 and ineffectually drag my bulk around Industrial Grotto, weeping and banging on locked corporate doors. United Knee Wrap's having a gala. Their top brass are drunkenly lip-synching hits of the '50s en masse and their foot soldiers are laughing like subservient fools, so no one hears my frantic knocking. I prepare to heave a fake boulder through the plate glass.
我冲过209号公路，徒劳地拖着我庞大的身躯绕过工业石窟，哭泣着拍打着紧锁的公司大门。联合膝盖包裹公司正在举行盛会。他们的高层醉醺醺地集体对口型演唱50年代的金曲，他们的走卒像顺从的傻瓜一样大笑，所以没人听到我疯狂的敲门声。我准备把一块假巨石扔过平板玻璃。
But then I stop. By now, Tim's beyond help. What do I gain by turning myself in? Did I or did I not save an innocent girl's life? Was he or was he not a cruel monster? And standing there outside the gala, I learned something vital about myself. When push comes to shove, I could care less about lofty ideals. It's me I love. It's me I want to protect. Me.
但我停下来了。现在，蒂姆已经没救了。我自首能得到什么？我救了一个无辜女孩的命，对吧？他是个残忍的怪物，对吧？站在盛会外，我对自己了解了一些重要的事情。当到了紧要关头，我根本不在乎那些高尚的理想。我爱的是我自己。我想要保护的是我自己。我自己。
I hustle back to the office for the burial gear. I roll Tim into the pit. I sprinkle on lime and cover him with dirt. I forge a letter in which he claims to be going to Mexico to clarify his relationship with God via silent meditation and a rugged desert setting. "My friends," I write through tears in his childish scrawl, "you slave away for minimal rewards. Freedom can be yours if you open yourself to the eternal. Good health and happiness to you all. I'm truly sorry for any offense I may have given. Also, I have thought long and hard on this and have decided to turn over the reins to Jeffrey whom I have always wrongly maligned. I see now that he is a man of considerable gifts and ask you all to defer to him as you would to me."
我匆忙跑回办公室拿埋葬装备。我把蒂姆滚进坑里。我撒上石灰，用土盖住他。我伪造了一封信，信中他声称要去墨西哥，通过静默冥想和粗犷的沙漠环境来澄清他与上帝的关系。“我的朋友们，”我含泪用他那孩子气的笔迹写道，“你们为微薄的报酬拼命工作。如果你向永恒敞开自己，自由就属于你们。祝你们健康快乐。我真的对任何我可能造成的冒犯表示歉意。另外，我对此思考良久，决定将指挥权移交给杰弗里，我一直错误地诋毁他。我现在看出他是一个有相当天赋的人，请求你们像对待我一样尊重他。”
I leave the letter on Claude's chair and go out to sleep in my car. I dream of Tim wearing a white robe in a Mexican cantina. A mangy dog sits on his lap explaining the rules of the dead. No weeping, no pushing the other dead, don't bore everyone with tales of how great you were. Tim smiles sweetly and rubs the dog behind the ears. He sees me and says no hard feelings and thanks for speeding him onto the realm of bliss.
我把信留在克劳德的椅子上，出去在车里睡觉。我梦见蒂姆穿着白袍在墨西哥小酒馆。一只邋遢的狗坐在他腿上，解释死后的规则。不要哭泣，不要推挤其他死者，不要用你生前有多伟大这类故事去烦扰大家。蒂姆甜甜地笑着，挠着狗的耳朵后面。他看见我，说没关系，谢谢我让他加速进入极乐世界。
I wake with a start. The sun comes up driving sparrows before it, turning the corporate reflective windows wild with orange. I roll out of my car and brush my teeth with my finger. My first day as a killer.
我惊醒了。太阳升起，驱赶着麻雀，把公司反射的窗户染得一片橘红。我滚出车，用手指刷牙。我成为杀手的头一天。
I walk to the pit in the light of fresh day hoping it was all a dream, but no. There's our scuffling footprints. There's the mound of fresh dirt, under which lies Tim. I sit on a paint can in a patch of waving weeds and watch my colleagues arrive. I weep. I think sadly of the kindly bumbler I used to be, bleary-eyed in the morning, guiltless and looking forward to coffee.
我在新的一天的光线下走向坑，希望这一切都是一场梦，但没有。那是我们挣扎的脚印。那是新土堆，蒂姆就躺在下面。我坐在飘扬杂草丛中的油漆桶上，看着我的同事到达。我哭泣。我悲伤地想起过去那个友好的笨拙的我，早晨睡眼惺忪，无辜又期待咖啡。
When I finally go in, everyone's gathered stunned around the microwave. "El Presidente," Claude says, disgustedly.
当我最终走进去时，每个人都震惊地围在微波炉周围。“总统先生，”克劳德厌恶地说。
"Sorry?" I say. I make a big show of shaking my head in shock as I read and reread the note I wrote. I ask if this means I'm in charge. Claude says with that kind of conceptual grasp, we're not exactly in for salad days. He asks Frieda if she had an inkling. She says she always knew Tim had certain unplumbed depths, but this is ridiculous. Claude says he smells a rat. He says Tim never had a religious bone in his body and didn't speak a word of Spanish. My face gets red. Thank God Blamphin, that toady, pipes up.
“抱歉？”我说。我大张旗鼓地摇着头，震惊地阅读并重读我写的字条。我问这是否意味着我负责。克劳德说就那种概念上的理解力，我们离好日子还远着呢。他问弗里达是否有预感。她说她一直知道蒂姆有一些不为人知的深度，但这太可笑了。克劳德说他闻到了一股老鼠味。他说蒂姆身上从来没有宗教骨头，也不会说西班牙语。我的脸变红了。感谢上帝，布兰芬，那个势利眼，插嘴了。
"I say in terms of giving Jeffrey a chance, we should give Jeffrey a chance. In as much as Tim was a good manager but a kind of a mean guy," he says.
“我说在给杰弗里一个机会方面，我们应该给杰弗里一个机会。既然蒂姆是个好经理但有点刻薄，”他说。
"Well put," Claude says cynically. "And I say this fatty knows something he's not telling." I praise Tim to the skies and admit I could never fill his shoes. I demean my organizational skills and leadership abilities but vow to work hard for the good of all. Then I humbly propose a vote. Do I assume leadership or not? Claude says he'll honor a quorum, and then via show of hands, I achieve a nice one. I move my things into Tim's office.
“说得好，”克劳德愤世嫉俗地说。“而我说这个胖子知道一些他没说的事。”我把蒂姆夸上了天，承认我永远填补不了他的位置。我贬低我的组织能力和领导才能，但发誓为大家的利益努力工作。然后我谦卑地提议投票。我担任领导与否？克劳德说他会尊重法定人数，然后通过举手表决，我得到了一个不错的结果。我把东西搬进了蒂姆的办公室。
Because he'd always perceived me as a hefty milquetoast with no personal aspirations, he trusted me implicitly. So I'm able to access the corporate safe. I'm able to cater in prime rib and a trio of mustachioed violinists who stroll from cubicle to cubicle hoping for tips.
因为他一直认为我是一个没有个人抱负的笨拙胖子，他完全信任我。所以我能进入公司保险箱。我能订购上等的肋排和三个留着胡子的小提琴手，他们满怀希望能拿到小费在隔间之间漫步。
Claude's outraged. Standing on his chair, he demands to know what ever happened to the profit motive. He says one can't run a corporation on good intentions and blatant naivete. He pleads that the staff fire me and appoint him CEO. Finally, Blamphin proposes I can him. Torson from Personnel seconds the motion. I shrug my shoulders and we vote and Claude's axed. He kicks the water cooler, he gives me the finger, but out he goes, leaving us to our chocolate mousse and cocktails.
克劳德气坏了。站在椅子上，他要求知道利润动机发生了什么事。他说一个人不能靠好的意图和明显的幼稚来经营公司。他恳求员工开除我，任命他为CEO。最后，布兰芬提议让我解雇他。来自人事部的托森附议了该动议。我耸耸肩，我们投票，克劳德被炒了。他踢了饮水机，对我竖中指，但他还是出去了，留给我们巧克力慕斯和鸡尾酒。
By nightfall, the party's kicked into high gear. I bring in jugglers and a comedian and drinks, drinks, drinks. My staff swears their undying loyalty. We make drunken toasts to my health and theirs. I tell them we'll kill no more. I tell them we'll come clean with the appropriate agencies and pay all relevant fines. Henceforth, we'll relocate the captured raccoons as we've always claimed to be doing. The company will be owned by us, the employees, who will come and go as we please. Day care will be available on site. Frieda brightens and sits on the arm of my chair.
夜幕降临，聚会进入高潮。我带了杂技演员、喜剧演员和饮料，喝吧，喝吧。我的员工发誓效忠于我。我们为我的健康和他们的健康喝醉酒祝酒。我告诉他们我们将不再杀生。我告诉他们我们将向有关机构坦白并支付所有相关罚款。从今以后，我们将像我们一直声称的那样重新安置捕获的浣熊。公司将由我们员工所有，我们想什么时候来就什么时候走。日托将在现场提供。弗里达心情变好，坐在我的椅子扶手上。
Muzak will give way to personal stereos in each cubicle. We will support righteous charities, take troubled children under our collective wing, enjoy afternoons off when the sun is high and the air sweet with the smell of mown grass. And when one of us finally has to die, we will have the consolation of knowing that, aided by corporate largess, our departed colleague has known his or her full measure of power, love, and beauty. And arm in arm, we will all march to the graveyard singing sad hymns.
背景音乐将被每个隔间的个人立体声音响取代。我们将支持正直的慈善机构，将问题儿童置于我们的集体羽翼之下，当太阳高照，空气中弥漫着割草的香气时，享受下午的休息。当我们中间的一员最终不得不死时，我们将得到慰藉，因为在公司的大方资助下，我们已故的同事已经体会到了他或她充分的权力、爱和美。我们将肩并肩，唱着悲伤的赞美诗向墓地前进。
Just then, the cops break in led by Claude, who's holding one of Tim's shoes. "If you went to Mexico," he shouts triumphantly, "wouldn't you take your Porsche? Would you be so stupid as to turn your life's work over to this tub of lard? Things started to add up. I did some literal digging. And there I found my friend Tim with a crushed rib cage that broke my heart and a look of total surprise on his face."
就在这时，警察闯了进来，带头的是克劳德，他手里拿着蒂姆的一只鞋。“如果你去了墨西哥，”他胜利地大喊，“难道你不带你的保时捷吗？你会蠢到把一生心血交给这桶猪油吗？事情开始加起来了。我做了一些字面意义上的挖掘。在那里，我发现了我的朋友蒂姆，胸腔被压碎，这让我心碎，他脸上带着完全惊讶的表情。”
"My Timmy," Frieda says, rising from my chair. "This disgusting pig killed my beautiful boy." They cuff me and lead me away.
“我的蒂米，”弗里达说着，从我的椅子上站起来。“这个恶心的猪杀了我的美男子。”他们给我戴上手铐，把我带走了。
In court, I tell the truth. The animal rights girl comes out of the woodwork and corroborates my story. The judge says he appreciates my honesty and the fact that I saved a life. He wonders why having saved a life, I didn't simply release Tim and reap the laurels of my courage. I tell him I lost control. I tell him a lifetime of scorn boiled over. He says he empathizes completely and says he had a weight problem himself when a lad. Then he gives me 50 as opposed to life without parole.
在法庭上，我说实话。动物权利女孩现身并证实了我的故事。法官说他感谢我的诚实以及我救了一条命的事实。他纳闷为什么救了命之后，我没有简单地释放蒂姆并收获勇气的桂冠。我告诉他我失控了。我告诉他一生的蔑视沸腾了。他说他完全感同身受，并说他在小时候自己也有体重问题。然后他判我50年，而不是终身监禁不得假释。
So now I know misery. I know the acute discomfort of a gray jail suit pieced together from two garments of normal size. I know the body odor of Vic, a Chicago kingpin who's claimed me for his own and compels me to wear a feminine hat with fruit on the brim for nightly interludes. Do my ex-colleagues write? No. Does Frieda? Ha. Have I achieved serenity? No. Do I have a meaningful hobby that makes the days fly by like minutes? No.
所以现在我知道了痛苦。我知道穿一件由两件正常尺码衣服拼接而成的灰色狱服的极端不适。我知道维克的体味，他是芝加哥的一个头目，他把我据为己有，强迫我在每晚的互动中戴上一顶上面有水果的女性帽子。我的前同事写信吗？没有。弗里达写吗？哈。我获得平静了吗？没有。我有一个让日子像分钟一样飞逝的有意义的爱好吗？没有。
I have a wild desire to smell the ocean. I have a sense that God is unfair and preferentially punishes his weak, his dumb, his fat, his lazy. I believe he takes more pleasure in his perfect creatures and cheers them on like a brainless dad as they run roughshod over the rest of us. He gives us a need for love and no way to get any. He gives us a desire to be liked and personal attributes that make us utterly unlikable. Having placed his flawed and needy children in a world of exacting specifications, he deducts the difference between what we have and what we need from our hearts and our self-esteem and our mental health. This is how I feel. These things seem to be true. But what's there to do but behave with dignity, keep a nice cell, be polite but firm when Vic asks me to shimmy while wearing a hat, join in at the top of my lungs when the geriatric murderer from Baton Rouge begins his nightly spiritual?
我有一种强烈的渴望去闻海洋的味道。我有一种上帝是不公平的，优先惩罚他的弱者、他的哑巴、他的胖子、他的懒汉的感觉。我相信他从他完美的创造物中获得更多乐趣，并像一个无脑的爸爸一样为它们加油，因为它们横行霸道地对待我们其余人。他给了我们对爱的需求，却没有任何方式可以得到。他给了我们被喜欢的渴望和让我们极其不可爱的个人属性。在把他那有缺陷和有需求的儿女安置在一个精确规格的世界后，他从我们的心、我们的自尊和我们的心理健康中扣除了我们所拥有的和我们需要之间的差额。这就是我的感受。这些事情似乎是真的。但除了表现得有尊严，保持一个好的牢房，在维克要我戴着帽子扭动时礼貌但坚定地拒绝，在巴吞鲁日的老年谋杀犯开始他每晚的灵性活动时大声加入，还能做什么呢？
Maybe the God we see, the God who calls the daily shots is merely a sub-god. Maybe there's a God above this sub-god who's busy for a few God minutes with something else and will be right back and when he gets back will take the sub-god by the ear and say, "Now look, look at that fat man. What did he ever do to you? Wasn't he humble enough? Didn't he endure enough abuse for 1,000 men? Weren't the simplest tasks hard? Didn't you sense him craving affection? Were you unaware that his days unraveled as one long bad dream?"
也许我们看到的上帝，那个每天发号施令的上帝只是个次级上帝。也许在次级上帝之上有个上帝，他正忙于其他几分钟的上帝时间，很快会回来，当他回来时，会抓住次级上帝的耳朵说：“现在看，看看那个胖子。他到底对你做了什么？他不够谦虚吗？他忍受的不够多吗？难道简单的任务不难吗？你没感觉到他渴望感情吗？你不知道他的一生就像一场漫长的噩梦吗？”
And maybe as this sub-god slinks away, the true God will sweep me up in his arms, saying, "My sincere apologies. A mistake has been made. Accept a new birth as token of my esteem." And I will emerge again from between the legs of my mother a slighter and more beautiful baby, destined for a different life in which I am masterful, sleek as a deer, a winner.
也许当这个次级上帝溜走时，真正的上帝会把我揽入怀中，说：“我真诚地道歉。出了个错。接受新的出生作为我尊敬的标志。”我会再次从我母亲的腿间出来，一个更轻盈、更美丽的婴儿，注定会有另一种生活，在那种生活中，我是掌控者，像鹿一样灵动，是一个赢家。
"The 400 Pound CEO" is in George Saunders' book of short stories CivilWarLand in Bad Decline .
《400磅重的首席执行官》收录在乔治·桑德斯的短篇小说集《内战乐园堕落记》中。
Act Three, Dead Animal Man. It's our program on dead animals and on human thoughts. This next story is a story recorded during the summer, years ago, in Washington DC. Society has a deal with people in certain unpleasant jobs. It pays them money, and they handle disgusting smelling stuff so nobody else has to. Well, meet Clarence Hicks.
第三幕，死动物人。这是我们关于死动物和人类思想的节目。下一个故事是多年前夏天在华盛顿特区录制的。社会与某些从事令人不快工作的人有协议。社会付钱给他们，他们处理恶心发臭的东西，这样就没人需要做了。好吧，见见克劳伦斯·希克斯。
I pick up dead animals. I'm a dead animal man. I pick up dead animals. Dead dogs, dead cats, whatever. That's just my job.
我捡死动物。我是个死动物人。我捡死动物。死狗、死猫，什么都行。那就是我的工作。
Washington DC has three dead animal catchers in the Department of Sanitation. This week, I went out with Clarence Hicks.
华盛顿特区在环卫部门有三名死动物捕获者。这周，我和克劳伦斯·希克斯一起出去。
What highway are we on here?
我们在哪条高速公路上？
295, southbound. It should down by Overlook.
295号，南向。应该在奥弗卢克附近。
So you've just picked up that--
所以你刚才捡起那个——
Bird.
鸟。
--bird. How long do you think that was there?
——鸟。你觉得它在那儿呆了多久了？
That's probably been there a couple days. It's body's going sucked all in, see. The worms and stuff ate him up.
可能在那儿呆了几天了。它的身体缩进去了，你看。蠕虫之类的东西把它吃光了。
OK, we're running across the highway now.
好了，我们现在正穿过高速公路。
It's a cat.
是只猫。
What is it?
是什么？
It's a cat. This is a cat. It's been here for a little while. Dried up, see?
是只猫。这是一只猫。它在这儿有一阵子了。干透了，你看？
It's all flat on one side.
它一边都平了。
Yep.
是的。
The cat's head was still normal, but the body was blackened and dissolving. Mr. hicks slid a pitchfork under the poor thing and carried it back to his truck, where he dropped it into a metal trash can in the back. It was hot. Summer is the busy season for dead animal catchers. More animals are outside so more are dead on the road. And then there's the smell to deal with. In the hot sun, the animals decompose fast.
猫的头还是正常的，但身体已经变黑并溶解了。希克斯先生把一把干草叉插进可怜东西下面，把它运回他的卡车，扔进后边的一个金属垃圾桶里。天气很热。夏天是死动物捕获者最忙的季节。更多的动物在外面，所以路上死的更多。还有需要处理的气味。在炎热的阳光下，动物腐烂得很快。
What sort of person does this kind of work? Clarence Hicks is 51 with a gray goatee. He has kids and grandkids, but no pets. Before taking this job a year and a half ago, he worked in other divisions in the Department of Sanitation, cleaning alleys, working at the city incinerator. He says this job is definitely a step up.
什么样的人做这种工作？克劳伦斯·希克斯51岁，留着灰色山羊胡。他有孩子和孙子，但没有宠物。在一年半前从事这份工作之前，他在环卫部门的其他部门工作过，清理小巷，在城市焚化炉工作。他说这份工作绝对是个升级。
I'm my own boss. I'm by myself. All they do is give me the work to do, I go get it. I don't have nobody bothering me all the time.
我自己就是老板。我自己一个人。他们只是给我工作做，我去拿。没人一直烦我。
Driving around alone.
独自开车。
And I'll be driving around. Yeah. Driving by myself. And I like that.
我会到处开车。是的。独自开车。我喜欢那样。
It's not very strenuous. Mostly Mr. Hicks stops by people's houses, picks up their dead pets, or dead animals in the neighborhood. Maybe a dozen a day. Few enough so he doesn't have to rush. A dispatcher gives him a list of animals and addresses over the radio.
这不是很吃力。希克斯先生大多数时候在人们家里停下来，捡走他们的死宠物，或者社区里的死动物。也许一天十几只。很少，所以他不用赶时间。调度员通过无线电给他一份动物和地址的列表。
OK, 2262 High Street SE. I took care of that, 10-4?
好的，东南区高街2262号。我处理那个了，收到？
10-4.
收到。
Hey, buddy, do you see a dead cat laying around anywhere?
嘿，哥们，你看到哪里有死猫吗？
A cat?
猫？
Yeah.
是的。
At one house, we were supposed to find a cat. But after looking in the street, in the backyard, everywhere, we only found a fish, 10 inches long, silver blue, in perfect condition, but dead.
在一户人家，我们本该找一只猫。但在街上、后院、到处找过之后，我们只找到一条10英寸长的鱼，银蓝色，状况完美，但死了。
Maybe they got confused.
也许他们搞混了。
Maybe so.
也许吧。
We had other stops. A cat under a tree, a dog covered with maggots. Over on 30th Place, we were called out for a squirrel.
我们还有其他站点。树下的一只猫，满是蛆的狗。在30街，我们接到电话去处理一只松鼠。
There it is.
在那儿。
There it is, right there.
在那儿，就在那儿。
It took less than a minute.
不到一分钟就搞定了。
Then I take him and put him in the truck here. After we get two put in the truck, we put it down. Then we go to the next stop. Pick up just--
然后我把它拿起来放进卡车里。我们装进去两只后，就把它放下去。然后我们去下一站。只捡——
People have strong personal reactions to dead animals. A stranger wearing a white cap and a beeper just walked up to us and started talking.
人们对死动物有强烈的个人反应。一个戴着白帽子和寻呼机的陌生人向我们走过来开始说话。
I'd have given half my life for that squirrel at one time. I was a prisoner during the Korean War. And I used to sit up off that Han River and watch seagulls fly over. I'd be laying there thinking I could fry one, that's how hungry I was. What, are you just riding around?
我曾经愿意为了那只松鼠付出半条命。我在朝鲜战争期间是个俘虏。我常坐在汉江边看海鸥飞过。我躺在那儿想我能炸一只，我当时有多饿。怎么，你们只是在兜风吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You know, animals got a right. We're killing most of them because we forced them off their land. I think they have as much right on Earth as man has, or human beings. And we forced them off. In fact, they were here first.
你知道，动物有权利。我们杀掉它们大多数是因为我们把它们赶出了它们的土地。我认为它们在地球上和人一样拥有权利，或者人类。是我们把它们赶走的。事实上，它们先到这里。
Are you the person who called it in to the Department of Sanitation to pick this up?
你是那个打电话给环卫部门来捡这个的人吗？
I saw it. Yeah. They'll be here in a short period of time. They'll pick up that before they pick up most human beings.
我看到了。是的。他们过一会儿就会来。他们捡这个比捡大多数人还快。
Back in the truck, Mr. Hicks said that in his job, you can't just throw the animals around. People will complain. You have to respect people's feelings about animals, be more funeral director than garbage man. Like yesterday, he said, when he picked up a woman's dog.
回到卡车上，希克斯先生说在这一行，你不能随便乱扔动物。人们会投诉的。你必须尊重人们对动物的感情，与其说是垃圾工，不如说是殡葬承办人。就像昨天，他说，当他捡起一个女人的狗时。
Yeah, she was really, really crying. It's a sad thing to see people really crying. And you'll be surprised about the animals. People are really crazy about animals.
是的，她真的，真的在哭。看到人们真的哭泣是件伤心的事。你会对动物感到惊讶。人们真的对动物很疯狂。
What was this animal yesterday?
昨天那只动物是什么？
It was a great big dog. A German Shepherd. And she really got attached to it.
是一只很大很大的狗。一只德国牧羊犬。她真的对它产生了感情。
So what did you do? What did you say?
那你做了什么？你说了什么？
I just said, well, I'm sorry you lost your dog. She just cried. So I asked her were you going to get another one? She said, I don't know. I might. I might get a dog. I don't know. So that's about the size of what you could do. So I just put him on the truck, onto the next stop.
我只是说，嗯，很抱歉你失去了你的狗。她只是哭。所以我问她你打算再养一只吗？她说，我不知道。可能会。我可能会养条狗。我不知道。这就是你能做的全部。所以我只是把它放上卡车，到下一站。
This is a big black dog.
这是一只大黑狗。
A big dog. A big black dog.
一只大狗。一只大黑狗。
The next stop for us was the animal shelter, where ordinary people bring their animals to be put to sleep, as they say. Mr. Hicks and another animal man, William Daniels, put on aprons and gloves and carried five big, gray, plastic barrels of animals into the truck, 50 or 60 animals in all.
我们的下一站是动物收容所，普通人把他们的动物带到那里去所谓的“安乐死”。希克斯先生和另一位动物人，威廉·丹尼尔斯，穿上围裙和手套，把五个大的、灰色的、塑料制的动物桶装进卡车，总共有50或60只动物。
And that garbage bucket had a couple of dogs, a couple cats.
那个垃圾桶里有几只狗，几只猫。
Cats, dogs--
猫，狗——
Dogs, cats, rats, squirrels, possums, all that.
狗，猫，老鼠，松鼠，负鼠，所有这些。
And now another dog.
现在还有另一只狗。
Another big dog.
另一只大狗。
Big German Shepherd here.
这儿有一只大德国牧羊犬。
All the animals are taken to what Mr. Hicks calls "The Box," a walk-in freezer near the city incinerator. There, the animals are lifted into metal oil barrels and left.
所有的动物都被带到希克斯先生所说的“盒子”，城市焚化炉附近的一个步入式冰柜。在那里，动物被提起放入金属油桶中留下。
Has this job changed the way that you see animals?
这份工作改变了你看待动物的方式吗？
To me? No. To me, they're dead, they're dead. There's no change in--
对我来说？没有。对我来说，它们死了就是死了。没有改变——
Come on. I don't believe you. I feel like I see animals differently just from seeing those dogs in one of those gray, plastic--
得了吧。我不相信你。我感觉我光是看到那些灰色的、塑料制的桶里的狗，看待动物的方式就变了——
How do you see them dead? Are you seeing them decomposed? You know they're dead, right?
你怎么看死去的它们？你是看到它们腐烂了吗？你知道它们死了，对吧？
Well, that's a new point of view.
嗯，那是一个新的观点。
OK, they'll be decomposed, you know they ain't alive, because if they were alive they'd be still running around here.
好了，它们会腐烂的，你知道它们不活着，因为如果它们活着，它们会还在到处跑。
I'll tell you, the next time I see a dog on the street, I'm going to think to myself-- I'm just going to remember what those dogs in the back of your truck looked like.
我告诉你，下次我在街上看到狗，我会对自己想——我只是会记得你卡车后面的那些狗看起来是什么样子。
Well, they looked dead, right?
嗯，它们看起来死了，对吧？
They looked dead, yeah.
它们看起来死了，是的。
OK. You know they are not alive. Because if they were alive, they'd be running around. If you see a live dog, you say, well, you be careful now, because one day, you may be back in the back there.
好了。你知道它们不活着。因为如果它们活着，它们会到处跑。如果你看到一条活狗，你说，好吧，你现在小心点，因为有一天，你可能会回到后面去。
Did you ever see those pictures of-- I guess it's the angel of death? You know, big black hood and a sickle, a guy holding a sickle? The Grim Reaper.
你有没有见过那些照片——我猜是死亡天使？你知道，大黑斗篷和镰刀，一个拿着镰刀的家伙？死神。
I've seen a picture of that guy. [INAUDIBLE] Why should I let that bother me?
我见过那家伙的照片。[听不清] 我为什么要让那困扰我？
Well, it shouldn't bother you because that's who you are for these dogs.
嗯，那不该困扰你，因为这就是你对这些狗的角色。
That's right.
那倒是。
That's you.
那个人就是你。
Well, no, I'm the angel. See, when they die, I'm going to take them to heaven. I'm the undertaker. I'm the undertaker. Keep them from laying on the streets, smelling, let birds pick on them and all that kind eat him or something like that. I take them off the street.
嗯，不，我是天使。你看，当它们死时，我会带它们上天堂。我是殡葬承办人。我是殡葬承办人。让它们不至于躺在街上发臭，让鸟啄它们，或者被别的什么东西吃掉。我把它们从街上带走。
Give them a decent disposal.
给它们一个体面的处置。
There you go.
就是这样。
A few times a week, a rendering company comes down from Baltimore to pick up the animals that Mr. Hicks has gathered and left in The Box. In Baltimore, these smelly creatures that nobody wants are changed into smelly things that people sell to each other, ingredients for perfume, fertilizer, stuff that ordinary folks can handle themselves.
每周几次，一家渲染公司从巴尔的摩过来捡走希克斯先生收集并留在盒子里的动物。在巴尔的摩，这些没人要的臭烘烘的生物被变成了人们互相买卖的香东西，香水、肥料的成分，普通人自己可以处理的东西。
Act Four, Redemption. So what if you took it as your mission to keep the animals from dying? Well, the hardest cases, the most abused, the sickest animals in trouble are Leo Brillo's purpose in life.
第四幕，救赎。那么如果你把阻止动物死亡作为你的使命呢？好吧，最困难的病例，最受虐待、最生病的陷入困境的动物是利奥·布里洛的人生目标。
I guess I can't stand the suffering of an animal. An animal looks up at you, and to me, I can feel what he's feeling as a human little thing. Or there's something going on. I don't just see a furry thing. I see the eyes and I get right into the feelings of the animal. And something affects me and I have to do something about it. I don't have that empathy, maybe, with people. Or maybe I don't allow it, to have that with people. Because somehow people can take care of themselves. These guys can't. These animals can't. So I see that and I have to do something about it. But I won't draw the line.
我想我无法忍受动物的痛苦。一只动物抬头看你，对我来说，我能感受到它作为一个人类小东西的感觉。或者发生了什么。我不仅看到一个毛茸茸的东西。我看到眼睛，我就直接进入了动物的感觉里。有什么影响了我，我必须对此做点什么。我也许没有那种与人的共情。或者也许我不允许自己与人有那种共情。因为某种程度上人可以照顾自己。这些家伙不能。这些动物不能。所以我看到了，我就必须做点什么。但我不会划清界限。
See, I can't go to the pound. I have meetings with the director, the whole set up out here. I can't go to the pound. He has to meet me in a coffee shop. Because if I go to the pound, I'm going to walk through, look at every animal, take every dog that's ready to be killed that day and bring them to the shelter. I can't do that. But I will. So for me, I know the weakness. The weakness is don't communicate. Don't be there. Just be removed. I can't go over the next hill if I don't have the room.
看，我不能去收容所。我和主任有会议，外面的整个设置。我不能去收容所。他必须在咖啡店见我。因为如果我去收容所，我会走过去，看每一只动物，带走每一只准备那天被杀的狗，把它们带到避难所。我不能那样做。但我会。所以对我来说，我知道弱点。弱点是不要沟通。不要在那儿。只是被移开。如果我没有空间，我不能去下一座山。
Still, there's just this thing inside of me that pulls me and I go into the next hill. And I find things all the time. I always find somebody when I do that. And this is my code. And this is the way I live. My one message to animals is if you're hungry or if you're hurt, cross my path. That's my message. And since the day I said that, I was in Hollywood, I told you, and I'm walking down the street and cats are jumping out in front of me ever since then.
尽管如此，我内心深处总有某种东西拉着我，我去下一座山。我总能发现东西。我那样做时总是发现某个东西。这是我的准则。这是我的生活方式。我对动物唯一的讯息是，如果你饿了或者受伤了，经过我的路。这是我的讯息。自从我那样说的那天起，我在好莱坞，我告诉过你，我正走在街上，从那时起猫就一直跳到我面前。
I mean, my friends, nobody has this problem. I go down the street and they pop out of everywhere. And they're limping or they're hungry or whatever. And that makes me feel OK that I don't have to worry about did I miss one. Because I'll say, no, he's OK because he didn't cross my path.
我是说，我的朋友们，没人有这个问题。我走在街上，它们从四处蹦出来。它们一瘸一拐，或者饿了，不管怎样。这让我觉得没关系，我不必担心我是否错过了一只。因为我会说，不，它没关系，因为它没经过我的路。
And it is the same way, it's the same thing when you have one that's very sick, making the same decision. You tell me, what am I supposed to do? I don't want you to suffer, but if you can make it, and do you want to make it, and all these other things being considered. And still, even then, it has to be suffering with absolutely no prognosis.
同样地，当你有一只病得很重的动物时，做同样的决定也是一样的事。你告诉我，我该怎么办？我不想让你受苦，但如果你能挺过来，你想挺过来吗，以及所有其他被考虑的因素。即便如此，那也必须是完全没有预后的受苦。
I have a dog at home that I got and it had distemper. It ended up this dog lost the use of its rear legs. The vet said put her down. No way, she lost the front legs. Now I'm carrying her in and out five times, six times a day. At night, I'm waking up twice to flip her over because she can't move. She had a heating pad on. She couldn't regulate her heat.
我家里有一只狗，是我捡的，它得了犬瘟热。结果这条狗失去了后腿的功能。兽医说安乐死。没门，她失去了前腿。现在我每天五次、六次把她抱进抱出。晚上，我醒来两次把她翻过来，因为她不能动。她有个电热垫。她不能调节自己的体温。
Everybody except my wife that heard about it said it's insane. We just stopped letting people know. The vet said, "How'd that dog do?" I said, "Oh, we put her down." I didn't tell them. Six weeks, I did this, back and forth. Because she wanted to make it. There was just something about her. One day, when I'm bouncing her up and down on her feet so she can get muscle tone, I'm bouncing her, and she's just limp. And all of a sudden, a foot goes out to get her balance.
除了我妻子，所有听到这件事的人都说这疯了。我们只是不再让人知道。兽医说：“那条狗怎么样了？”我说：“哦，我们安乐死了。”我没告诉他们。六周，我这样做，来来回回。因为她想挺过来。她身上有什么东西。有一天，当我在她脚上上下弹动她让她得到肌肉张力时，我在弹她，她只是软绵绵的。突然，一只脚伸出来保持平衡。
And it was the best thing-- Bailey put a foot out. Two weeks later, she could walk. Now she's running, tearing up. We've had her a year and a half now of tearing up everything. I mean, she's just-- she always remembers that she was appealing to live. And she just needed somebody to give her the chance. I give them everything I can if they want to make it. If they want to live, there's something about it, they fight. I fight with them.
那是最好的事情——贝利伸出了一只脚。两周后，她能走了。现在她能跑，能搞破坏了。我们已经养了她一年半了，一直在搞破坏。我是说，她总是记得她曾经恳求活着。她只是需要有人给她机会。如果它们想活下去，我尽我所能给它们。如果它们想活下去，有什么东西，它们会战斗。我和它们一起战斗。
I have a cat at home. He had leukemia. He got cancer, he got lymphosarcoma. He has tumors and he's building up with fluid. And we did a special new surgery. We put a tube inside him. And twice a day, I use that tube to pull fluid out of him. He's in no pain and he purrs constantly. He just purrs and purrs and purrs, and he eats. And the most important thing is to make him well. And even then, it's only for a few months. I mean, you know he's going to get it eventually. And I said, it's amazing, but we only really pay that kind of attention and that kind of devotion to them when they're in that kind of trouble.
我家里有一只猫。他得了白血病。他得了癌症，得了淋巴肉瘤。他有肿瘤，体内积水。我们做了特殊的新手术。我们在他体内放了一根管子。一天两次，我用那根管子从他体内抽水。他没受苦，一直在打呼噜。他只是打呼噜、打呼噜、打呼噜，他吃东西。最重要的事情是让他好起来。即便如此，也只是几个月。我是说，你知道他最终会得那病的。我说，这很神奇，但我们只在它们陷入那种麻烦时，才真正给予那种关注和那种奉献。
That could be it. My wife has another answer. She says when they're that close to death, they become perfect. And that's the attraction. I don't know. They're becoming-- they know more. All of a sudden, they know. They know what's going on. They know here and beyond and they know what the hell we're doing caught up in the middle of the two. And they know something. And whatever it is, it changes them. And they become worth more if that's possible. I don't know. Just give them every shot. And let me see what's going on out there.
那可能是这样。我妻子有另一个答案。她说当它们接近死亡时，它们就变得完美了。这就是吸引力。我不知道。它们正在变得——它们知道更多。突然之间，它们知道了。它们知道发生了什么。它们知道此时此地和彼岸，它们知道我们到底在两者中间被困住做了什么。它们知道某些东西。不管是什么，它改变了它们。如果可能的话，它们变得价值更高。我不知道。只是给它们每一个机会。让我看看外面发生了什么。
[DOGS BARKING]
[狗吠声]
That story from producer Jay Allison.
那个故事来自制片人杰伊·艾利森。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Peter Clowney and Alix Spiegel. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Music help today by John Conners.
好吧，我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和我制作，彼得·克劳尼和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔协助。特约编辑保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。约翰·康纳斯提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like a copy of this program, it only costs $10. You can call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果您想要本节目的副本，只需10美元。您可以致电芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who does not want to be referred to as--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他不想被提到为——
Sexless and good, but very, very tense.
无性且善良，但非常、非常紧张。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Talk about the fall of man. Talk about some father somewhere being crestfallen if he knew what his daughter was up to.
谈谈人类的堕落吧。谈谈某个父亲如果知道他女儿在干什么会多么失望。